I'm a psychoanalytic thinker.
And what that means is that I believe that people are collections of some
personalities and that those subpersonalities are alive.
They're not machines.
They're there.
They have their viewpoint,
they have their wants,
they have their perceptions,
they have their arguments,
they have their emotions,
they're,
they're like low resolution representations of you.
You know,
when you get angry,
it's like,
it's a very low resolution representation of you.
It only wants rage or it only want something to eat or only once,
only once water only wants sex.
It's,
it's,
it's you,
but shrunken,
focused in a specific direction.
And,
and those,
all those motivational systems are very,
very ancient,
very archaic and very,
very powerful.
And they you up determining role in the manner in which we manifest ourselves.
As Freud pointed out with the kid,
we have to figure out how to take all those underlying animalistic motivations
and emotions and civilize them in some way so that we can all live in this same
general territory without tearing each other to shreds,
which is maybe the default position of both chimpanzee and humanity.
So,
so I take that seriously.
The idea that we're a loose collection of spirits and that that that,
that you know what it says in the Old Testament somewhere that the fear of God
is the beginning of wisdom and I think this is akin to that.
If you know that you're not in control of yourself thoroughly and that there are
other factors behind the scenes,
like the Greeks thought that human beings where the play things of the gods,
that's the way they conceptualize the world.
They sort of meant the same thing.
They meant that there are these great forces that that move us,
that we don't create that were,
that were,
that were subordinate to in some sense,
not entirely,
but we could be subordinate to them and they move our destinies.
That was the Greek view,
and there's something indeed it,
it teaches you humility to understand that,
that,
that there's a hell of a lot more going on behind the scenes and you're,
you're the driver of a very complex vehicle,
but you don't understand the vehicle very well.
And it's got its own motivations and methods and sometimes you think it's doing
something and it's doing something completely,
completely different.
You see that in psychotherapy all the time because you know,
you help someone unwind a pattern of behavior that they've manifested forever.
First of all,
they describe it,
then they become aware of it.
Then maybe they start to see what the cause is.
They had no idea why they were acting like that.
You know,
they have to have the memory that produced the behavioral pattern to begin with.
It has to be brought back to mind and then it has to be analyzed and assessed
and then they have to think about a different way of acting.
And it's extraordinarily complex.